Elon Musk has just offered an absolute
master class in how to handle
the powerful establishment lives and he
did so in an interview with the BBC
I just want to go Moment by moment to
enjoy this delectable lesson
in rhetoric it would describe a hateful
thing yeah I mean you know this content
that will solicit a reaction something
that may include something that is
slightly racist or slightly sexist those
kinds of those kinds of things so you
think if something is slightly sexist it
should be bent
so the the conversation begins with
with the accusation that under Elon
musk's pro-free speech or more pro-free
Speech Twitter rain
there's more hateful content on the site
that's the meme that's the talking point
from the liberal establishment so how
does Elon begin he doesn't say how dare
you I didn't do that that's a lie and X
Y and Z here are the reasons why he says
what's an example
give me just one example of the thing
that you're talking about or give me a
more precise description
and the BBC Journal says well you know
I have some things sort of slightly
racist or sexist and so then Elon takes
the Free Speech approach he says you're
telling me if something is slightly
sexist he doesn't focus on Race because
being called a racist is the worst thing
you can be called in our culture he
focuses on sex he says something is
slightly sexist
whatever that means is it sexist to say
men and women are different
is it sexist to say men and women aren't
different is what does that even mean
then you're telling me it should be
banned the BBC journalist says well no
not not exactly not saying anything I'm
just curious I'm trying to say what you
mean by hateful content and I'm asking
for specific examples
um and if and you just said that if
something is slightly sexist
that's hateful content does that mean
that it should be bad well you've asked
me you've asked me whether my feed
whether it's got less or more I'd say
it's got slightly more that's why I'm
asking for examples can I can you name
one example okay this is this is a key
so Elon Musk Begins by asking really for
just more of a definition of what the
guy's talking about but then the guy
brings up his own experience so the BBC
guy can't give a better definition or a
better description
because he's just parroting mindlessly
the establishment talking point beep
boop Twitter more hateful
South African man bad
so awful what they do today Elon Musk
one of the most prominent African
Americans in the world and these racist
whites they just attack him
it's a point for another time so Elon
says okay well
now that you've brought your own Twitter
feed into this forget about giving me a
better description
give me a concrete example of what
you're talking about because Elon is is
inferring here he's suspecting that hold
on this guy he's starting to change his
story a little bit I'm going to press
even harder honestly don't you I I
honestly I can't name a single example
I'll tell you why because I don't
actually use that for you feed anymore
because I just don't particularly like
it but you said to a lot of people a lot
of people are quite similar I I only I
only look on a second you said you've
seen more hateful content hold on now
there it is now now elon's got him so he
says what describe hateful content well
you know if it's a little bit like this
or that this or that
can you
can you go further well I've just
noticed in my own feed you know it's my
Twitter feed is much more hateful
oh okay well what's what's a concrete
example of that well actually I don't
really use my Twitter feed so now elon's
got him because now he's just caught
this guy in a lie the LIE is I've
noticed that my Twitter feed has gotten
more hateful
says okay show me an example oh I
actually don't use my Twitter feed oh so
now I can't trust a word that you're
saying and one of the keys that allowed
Elon to suspect that that's what's going
on here is that the the BBC guy was
talking in very vague terms and he was
always hedging his bets well it's
slightly sexist oh it's a little more
hateful well I'm just kind of noticed
okay that's a sign you have no idea what
you're talking about and on top of that
you're a liar so now Elon just destroys
this guy with facts and logic became a
single example not even one I'm not sure
I've used that feed for the last
because I've been I've been using I've
been using Twitter since you've taken
over for the last six months okay so
then you must have at some point seen
that you're for you hateful content I'm
asking for one example right you can't
give a simple one and I'm saying I say
Sir that you don't know what you're
talking about really yes because you
can't be a single example of hateful
content not even one tweet and yet
you're claimed that the hateful content
was high well that's a false no what I
could just lied what no no what I claim
was uh there are many uh organizations
that say that that kind of information
is on the rise now whether whether it
has happened again there it is uh that
now he's changed his story again
so Elon just asks a very basic question
how have you seen an uptick in hateful
content if you haven't seen anything in
your Twitter feed well no I just know
because I used it before yeah you used
it before you're alleging an uptick in
hateful content
and you by the way you can't even give
me one example from that period of time
so what are you talking about and then
once you do he changes the story again
he goes no well I've just
I just read reports you know from these
liberal
from these other liberal sources and the
reports say it so I'm just I'm gonna
restate that as fact and I'm gonna lie
and pretend it's been my own experience
but yeah it's from Liberal Outlets that
hate you
he goes on someone like the Strategic
dialogue Institute in the U in the UK
they will say that so you they look
people will say all sorts of nonsense
I'm literally asking for a single
example and you can't name one right all
sorts of nonsense that this this BBC guy
I think he's being sincere in his
disregard for the truth I think he comes
by that honestly he comes by his
dishonestly honestly he thinks well
that's just no that's just how all
people talk we just recite the liberal
talking points I Didn't Do It
consciously I just that's just what I do
and then
I well no I but it everybody's saying it
it's the that's what the outlets are
that's what beep it's like it's like
Elon broke his brain
and and what does Elon say he says yep
people say all sorts of nonsense
so like when when now that I'm on the
road I'm going to these college campuses
when I talk to a young liberal
especially on an issue like
transgenderism which is so manifestly
absurd but which the liberal
establishment has doubled and tripled
and quadrupled down on
they'll look at me
with this pitiful stare they'll look at
me and they won't have anything to say
because they'll all they'll be able to
say is but
I was told this was true I but everybody
everybody says this is true that men can
be women
the answer to which is exactly what Elon
said here yeah people say all sorts of
nonsense
it doesn't make it true how is it true
give me any example and the poor BBC guy
you all he's a liar but you you almost
feel for him because he's just he's
squirming
trying to dig himself out of this hole
of lies that he stood for himself use
that feed but how did you know that I
don't think this is getting anything you
literally said you experienced more
hateful content and then couldn't name a
single example right and as I said
that's absurd I haven't I haven't
actually looked at that feed but how
would you know this beautiful content
because I'm saying that's what I saw a
few weeks ago I can't give you an exact
example let's move on we have we only
have a certain amount of time
um well
yeah let's move on that's that's
probably your best bet I haven't
actually seen it but no I did see it but
I didn't but I read a report and I heard
it from a person and anyway let's move
on and elon's response is just perfect
wow
Elon Musk is more intelligent than
most people in public life
probably pretty much anybody in public
life he's he's up there okay but Elon
Musk talks in really plain terms
that is a sign of intelligence
and what the a lot of people are loath
to do that because a lot of
conservatives feel intimidated by the
Liberals the Liberals will use all these
fancy words all this academic jargon
they've got all their studies oh we have
our studies that can show you absurd
things that we know are not true and so
a lot of people don't want to speak in
plain language
the smartest people throughout all of
history
have by and large spoken in really plain
language Plato writes in a way that is
clear and concise and can be understood
by a 15 year old just as much as by a 50
year old
it's it's the people who use all sorts
of silly jargon and who try to dance
around facts and coin all these
neologisms those are the people
who you've got to watch out for and so
when Elon Musk speaks in these plain
terms that that's how we all want to
speak
why is
why is transgenderism wrong
because men can't be women but you don't
even understand
expression and
not even if I had no need to read some
20th century weirdo to know what we all
know to be true intuitively there's
those plain words even that very end of
the very end of the interview wow
yeah wow we have got a great
AI
challenge coming up from Mr Davies over
on the member block so much to get to so
much more I had to say today we'll get
to a little bit in the member block
we'll get to a lot more tomorrow and
we'll get to a little bit tonight at UW
Superior if you're not a member become
one at dailywire.com Knowles promo code
Knowles k-n-w-l-e-s get two months free
on all annual plans
see you over at the member block
[Music]